Die gesamte Nordhalbkugel ist heiß.
Zum ersten Mal haben Klimawissenschaftler,
diese Situation konkret mit dem Klimawandel
in Zusammenhang gebracht.
Und jetzt wurde eine Studie veröffentlicht,
die einen wirklich dramatischen Wandel vorhersagt.
Demnach stehen wir vor einer Heißzeit.
Herzlich willkommen zu Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Gestern waren die nachrichten wieder voll
davon.
Waldbrände.
In Kalifornien ist der größte Waldbrand
der Geschichte des Landes ausgebrochen.
115.000 Hektar sind inzwischen verbrannt,
mehr als tausend Häuser wurden zerstört.
14.000 Feuerwehrleute sind im Einsatz.
das Feuer ist nicht unter Kontrolle.
Es wird frühestens mit dem 15. August gerechnet,
bis es kontrolliert werden kann.
Das sind wirklich riesige Flächen, die dort
zerstört werden und es wird jedes jahr schlimmer.
Wir müssen wohl in Zukunft damit rechnen,
dass große Flächen abbrennen.
Es wird bei solchen Temperaturen und solcher
Trockenheit selbst hier in Mitteleuropa oder
sogar Skandinavien (wir hatten darüber berichtet)
nicht mehr zu vermeiden sein.
Flüsse trocknen hier aus.
Ernten sind total gering.
Undsoweiter undsofort.
Und jetzt haben Klimaforscher und -forscherinnen
bei dieser Entwicklung sogenannte Kippsysteme
analysiert.
das sind Systeme, die wenn ihre Veränderung
durch den Klimawandel angestoßen wird, den
Klimawandel noch beschleunigen.
Zum Beispiel ist das das schwindende Eis in
der Arktis, wodurch weniger Sonnenlicht zurück
ins Weltall reflektiert wird.
Permafrostböden, die wenn sie tauen, das
Klimagas Methan freigeben.
Abholzung des Amazonas Regenwaldes, wodurch
weniger CO2 in Sauerstoff umgewandelt wird.
Methanhydrate am Meeresboden, die wenn sie
tauen auch Methan freigeben.
Undund und Der Effekt all dieser Kippsysteme
könnte wie bei Dominosteinen funktionieren.
System für System kippt undzwar ganz ohne,
dass es noch mehr CO2 in der Atmosphäre bedürfte.
Johan Rockström, Direktor des Stockholm Resilience
Centre und wird Kodirektor des Potsdam-Instituts
für Klimafolgenforschung (PIK).
"Wird einer von ihnen gekippt, schiebt dieses
Element die Erde auf einen weiteren Kipppunkt
zu."
Und durch diese Kettenreaktion wird der Klimawandel
dann automatisch immer mehr verstärkt.
Zum beispiel könnte der Verlust des Eises
in der Westantarktis schon soweit fortgeschritten
sein, dass der Kipppunkt dort schon überschritten
sei, meint Hans Joachim Schellnhuber vom PIK.
Dann würde die Antarktis umfangreich abschmelzen.
Die Studie hält als Folge eine Heißzeit
für wahrscheinlich.
Die Erde würde sich dann um vier bis fünf
Gard erwärmen und der Meeresspiegel um 10
bis 60 Meter steigen.
Weite Landstriche der Erde müssten verlassen
werden.
Eine Flüchtlingsbewegung unbekannten Ausmaßes
käme in Gang.
Bei welchen Temperaturen diese Kettenreaktionen
der Kippsysteme allerdings beginnt kann heute
niemand sagen.
Trotzdem warnen Forscher davor, dieses Risiko
zu ignorieren.
Die Politik muss also endlich mal wirklich
reagieren und konkretere Schritte unternehmen.
dass, wie wir hier erst vor Kurzem berichtet
haben, das Klimarisiko Fleischproduktion ignoriert
wird, ist schlichtweg unverantwortlich.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und zu allen anderen
Themen verpassen wollt, dann added mich bei
WhatsApp.
Dann umgeht ihr die etwas unzuverlässige
Abobox hier auf YouTube und ihr verpasst kein
Video.
Denn über WhatsApp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem Upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
- täglich garantiert.
Einfach hier draufklicken.
Und am besten auch meinen Schwesterkanal Clixoom
Social & Media abonnieren.
Da gibt es das neueste aus der Social Media-Welt.
Dafür hier klicken, aber nicht die Glocke
vergessen.
Hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf auch
klicken) „Sommer 2018: Unser kampf gegen
die Hitze!“ Bis dann, bleibt dran!